*Slap* (ow, mark, wtf)
The haunted house pop-up shop worked incredibly well, better than I could have ever hoped,
but there's more that we could do.
What is a pop-up shop really about? At its base level, a pop-up shop is a clothing store that pops up out of nowhere
That's how it all started!
way back in the early 80s or 90s or whenever the hell it actually first started
- I don't know when.
But it did!
at some point some Mr. Pop-up
Decided that it was time to go sell clothes on the corner and people went BANANAS for it.
People went apeshit!
But I can do one better, because if there's one thing that people said about me
It's that I have no sense of style, no sense of fashion,
Nothing about me screams that I planned anything that I did today.
Anyway, we can make a pop-up shop
And we can make a pop-up shop better than everybody else did... because we got a fan
What does a pop-up shop need, and what do I need to get rid of?
*Aggressive dotting*
Clothes, it's an anagram: Clothes. Lose. Original. Taste. Hence...
Everything. Sale! :D
Makes sense? *yes mark* okay cool, and number two you need
pop-up! People. Only. Purchase...
Unsold. Products. Makes sense??
and then number three... *processes number three*
*sound of marker on thy board*
I need to let go.
Let's. Emotionally. Traumatize...
Get. Out. *visible sadness*
We're gonna bring my clothes to the office
*do you hear that? that's the sound of Extra Grande, Extra-Large*
*falls*
*closes door*
*exotic movement*
ding!
*elevator music*
Oh, oh, oh! Heh, heeh - whatever.
*Mark yelling*
*box falls violently down stairs*
*goes to observe the damage with concern*
Yesh!
Here's some of my old clothes
And the reason I'm doing my old clothes because I'm not gonna go out and buy clothes and try to resell it. This is vintage!
This has history!!!
This is a classic!!!
I dont want to let go of it! :(
Oh these are the pants from the Lonely instinct!
oh, oh no these are the Bulge pants!
ah GOD! *visual discomfort*
oo, disco discomfort *sniffs* mmm... I did not wash that.
oh, this was from the deer, uh the- the- the- thethethethe
the- the deer man... video! oh *sniffs again and coughs*  oh man. *eww, mark*
mmm, help meee... sort through
NO! >:( Don't you dare, not even a little bit.
It took me years to get this back...
*Glare / Akward silence*
Don't.
It is!  It is what it is! I got this shirt for $5.00 at Walmart... *sobs*
*whispers* I can probably sell it for $20.
Oh, this is- oh theseee are the Lonely Instinct pants. Oh, hell yeah.
I'm gotta put these on
*Grunting*
*Cough*
Oh, the leather!
what nOoW
what nOW, Oh
Lonely instinct indeed
*slaps knee*
I've lost weight since I last wore this... fits even better now
oh no, no, no, nO, nOO
oh God
No, I think we got that no way in hell I'm giving away an elusive shirt.
I think that's a good pile. Good enough, anyway
*car door shuts*
Alright, okay, so what we got to do,
To have a successful pop-up shop,
You need to have more than one person engaged, right?
So we got to contact someone who might have some extra clothes that he's maybe grown out of
because he's a big boy now!
he turned 21, and he's a-a big bouncing baby boy that needs to be...
*mark! no texting and driving*
asked for some clothes!
so when you got a big bouncing bo- h-hello! Hi!
Hey! How's it going?
we're doing a pop-up shop
and...
We're hoping that you... have some clothes that you'd like to donate to the car.
Ethan: That's such perfect timing
Ethan: 'cause I absolutely do
Mark: Oh you do, oh perfect! oh great!
Ethan: Does it matter if they're dirty or clean?
Mark: We're gonna clean them maybe I don't know
Ethan: Okay
Okay, alright, well we're right outside your apartment
*Ethan knocks on the window*
Hello!
Do I have clothes?
Mark: Yeah, Ethan: Yeah
where are they?
uhh in my apartment
Uh, I have soy sauce.
I have cake! I have- *Interuppted by shuffling*
Ethan: theseee....
*Music of Tin foil*
Mozzarella sticks that have been there for... *Deep thought*
A while.
*sound of Mark eating mozzarella stick*
A little hard.... Mark: ugghhh *disgusted face*
You may not want it..
Do you want a shower curtain?
Mark: no! Ethan: *quietly* okay
Mark: Yes! Ethan: yeah!
Mark: yeah!-
Ethan: You have various items if you want
Are you just gonna give me extra *Inaudible* room?
You could have... this, which we used. That could be a very valuable item.
ahhhh!
this is from the uh Christmas Caaaan Wait- Can't wait!
here you play with that one.
*yayy, thanks markipoo*
Mark: Hang out here for a bit
*snow globe continues to play music*
Mark: Is that a dead body?
Having fun?
I literally only asked for clothes.
Do you want any Xbox one games?
Mark: uhhhhhhh,
Ethan : 'cause I dont.
Ethan: I feel like there's more I could give you-
nooo, we don't need it.
We stashed for clothes, now we have stuff.
Ethan: You want..-
Mark: don't want!
Mark: Already sayin' no!
*Face of regret*
Mark: *whispers* we should just leave-
Ethan in the distance : Uhh...
Ethan: Where you- where you going?
Mark: no! Oh
Ethan: wait, you could have more. Do you want a poster??
Mark: a what-
Ethan: a poster... Mark: of what?
Ethan: I'll show you.. *goes to get poster*
*takes opportunity to escape*
Ethan: No! Nah ya' don't need it.
Mark: thanks, see ya!
Ethan: hold on wait you forgot your... Mark: oh Ethan: mozzarella sticks..
*shuts door on a confused Mark*
*slowly sets bowl down*
Mark: No no, Chica, no
Mark: *whispers* Let's just go
*goes to get mozzarella sticks back*
Ethan: :D
*door slams shut*
Okay all right, so we're engaged and we're ready to go.
We need to move over, we need to clean this stuff.
We need to filter out whatever Ethan got that is garbage, which a lot of it is.
Stick to the plan.
We gotta make a pop-up shop, and we got to make it happen good
*Redneck Voice* Beep, beep beep beep-
BONK!
Alright, pup, you ready to set up shop? You ready to be an entrepreneur!!
Launch day is always so stressful. *stress intensifies*
What we need to do, we need to get uh
The MERchandise
and a good... setup so that people can browse at their leisure.
We've got my clothes
We've got Ethan's uh actual clothing contributions in this bad boy here, here put this out
We got the Google shirt, set it up right there.
I think in a rush
We forgot to wash the clothes, but I think people want that *sniffs* Musk
ooo, authentic dear man shirt- er pants
*Slap slap* Ubba
flap- classic- black-
I'm caring less and less
shoo
and all this... junk.
And then whatever Ethan has in this bag. What did he actually give us... pants?
Why??- Why!
Why did he give us bay leaves?
Shirt, shirt, shirt.
but all that aside, we need to advertise!
When you look at this, what do you see?
Untapped potential *Untapped potential intensifies*
the potential for anything, and most importantly the potential for advertising.
*writes "MARKIPLIER" in terrible, green marker.*
That's not legible at all
ah.. *makes weird noises*
That says boutique. Markiplier has been to the boutique
Pretty good, right. We need a logo of course.
we need a logo that represents...
infinite potential
*writes an 8*
So an infinity sign, 'cause there's- 'cause it's- well the- the clothing is both timeless, and has so many possibilities
And you're always moving forward. *draws a penis without realizing*
*Stares at poorly drawn penis*
*Zooms into poorly drawn penis rapidly*
*Looks at Mark*
Yeah! Here take a picture. Let's advertise this.
*sound of camera*
Why didn't you tell me that looks like a penis?
put a sweet filter on thaaat!
save that,
post it,
"Open for business," yeahh
Fan: Mark! Mark!
The customers are already rolling in!
Please browse our wares as you can see I've got an assortment...
of uh...
Lovely lovely lovely merchandise over here- Oh hello!
girl: this is my friend, Shelby.
hello! girl: this is another friend
W-welcome to the boutique!
We have...
A rejected version of the new holographic team *girl laughs*
see, it has no holographic at all
girl: oh- Mark: that means it's one of a kind
girl: it is!-
This will never be made, because it was a mistake. so the first sample will be free
But then you'll keep coming back for more, right? you'll get addicted to the product.
girl: yeahh Mark: I see how it is, there you go!
girl: thank youu! Mark: you're welcome
Are you in a struggle, I'll hold chica
ok, holographic *gets holographic shirt*
ok, yes yes, yes duhhh...
$2.75, $2.75
girl: uhhh I got 30. Mark: you got 30... cents?
girl: $35. Mark: $35? Girl: yeah-
Mark: uhhh, yeah 5. 5, 5, 5. girl: 5 5. Mark: 5? (both continue to repeat 5)
girl: high five? *laughs* there's the five! I'm still gonna give you the five I gotta go get it in the car *laughs*
Mark: You better not drive off with that! *laughing* I'm not running a free shop here!!
girl: I promise, I promise!
*runs to her car*
*looks at the others suspiciously*
For sale! we got it! yes! you hold on to that money.
alright, alright, alright, what else we got? c'mon, c'mon c'mon c'mon
oh, oh, vintage! vintage, vintage!
Does it come
how about $1?
guy: I have a dollar
oh you-you want this?
going for $1, $1, $1, $1 *at this point Mark is very desperate it seems*
guy: one for one dollar- Mark: $1- aND sold!
alright, 50 cents, 50 cents starting at 50 cents
guy: you got change for 20?
No dammit!
Why didn't we bring any change??
*I dunno*
ooo! These are the... Java pants that were in the Deer Man video
the pants that I wore!
guy: and you murdered me?
Yeah
*inaudible*
That's okay
girl: you've worn them?
yes! *laughs*
that's how it's vintage
girl: oh God- Mark: obviously *laughs*
$5? ($5)  *looks at us for approval*
other girl: got anything better?
wha- you-
girl: wait- what do you mean better!!!
(what do you mean better??)
(does he have anything else better!!!)
alright, from the friend yoga video, "this guy loves cats,"
other girl: that's so much better
two for one combo?
girl: $5
$5 for both
$5 for both? YES YES YES
*laughing
Ethan, uh CrankGamePlay's pants. Worn by the man, blue boy himself!
girl: I have another dollar
perfect, you have another pants
this is a shirt that I've worn in many videos,
This is very very important to me
eh-emotionally this is- this is heartbreaking to get rid of,
even though I bought it at Walmart for (guy: a penny!) $5
a penny??
guy: I'm running on change here right now, I'm sorry.
All right a dollar- I mean in my mind it's worth a thousand dollars, but it's-... dollar
Agh!
Ethan Nestor shower curtain!
Has probably touched his naked body
girl: oh God!
mmm!
Alright fine whatever
the ultimate sale
guy: no way!
my... real...
girl: $20
no, i'm not for selling this, what are you thinking?
guy: no waaay!
in what world would I sell that???
Alright, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
*snow globe plays music*
girl: Merry Christmas everybody!
You guys- I'm getting swept out!
by just this side
*laughing*
Thank you. AIright, I think we're officially sold out
*girl appears* girl: hi!
You're too late. We're sold out.
girl: *Has a seizure* SHIT!
oh, but I know what you'd want
girl: what?
wearin' a wowy shirt, eh? Girl : No... Guess who's shower curtain this is?
girl: wHat? *quietly* w h y
You see those stains? that's 100 percent Ethan Nestor.
oh yeah
(oh my god!)
I know!
yeah!
huhhh?
oOO
girl: oh my God
wha- Run!
alright, uhh
*funky music in background
Yeah, we're- we're sold out
(pretty good, right?)
Guy: Yeah, I'm happy. Mark: Well... Girl: Made a lot of money.
Get the fuck out.
Okay, we're leaving- that was incredibly successful- what's our haul, how much money did we make?
Aghh... what a successful sale... what a successful sale!
This is how I build
From the ground up
You know, it's about how much work you put in you put in work you get out reward that's how you do it
it also helps to have amazing fans
Who are willing to uh, buy Ethan's shower curtain... which is a strange thing but pretty cool?
So, thanks so much for your help, and uh, thank you everybody to came out, you know?
it's a big shout out to them
they're awesome people in them, so we're happy to have them with us, you know but!
There'll be more adventures later on so... *smiles*
Thanks again, and uh, as always
see ya in the next one, buh-bye!!
*bye mark!!*